hey what's up my name's samuel leet i'm
a property investor and i
am excited because serviced
accommodation
is opening back up on the 4th
of july now it's beginning to slowly
happen already
people are taking bookings again but the
government have officially said
that on the 4th of july hotels service
departments are going to be opened back
up for the public to book
what does that mean well that means for
a start
i'm beginning to my prophecies are
beginning to come true
it's very obvious i mean i said this a
month ago people were saying oh surface
accommodations dried up what are we
gonna do what's happening i said listen
hold it out because very very soon
they're going to open it back up of
course they're going to open it back up
just like the rest of the economy
everything's been closed down
everyone's been having difficulties and
challenges and having to adapt
hotels haven't been able to make money
in business so
service accommodation is no different
but right now with it opening back up
what's going to happen well here's what
i think is going to happen this is my
optimistic
prediction okay number one is the
government are encouraging people to
spend spend spend
and people have been locked down for
months i think people are going to want
to travel
i really do i think people are going to
be like right i don't want to be in my
house right now i want to go and stay
at somewhere i want to go stay at a new
house a hotel
i want to go and visit a new place a new
city they're going to want to go and
visit family and friends
and i think that it's going to really
begin bubbling up again another thing is
this
so many people that had their properties
on service accommodation
when lockdown came and they closed off
bookings they got scared and they got
worried
and they switched it back to a normal
buy to let property
so what's happened is i think the demand
is going to go
up and i think the supply i know the
supply is less because i've seen
loads of people's stories that they've
stopped they've
closed down their service departments
they've closed down their little hotel
businesses
because of because of covet 19. so if
the
listen this is basic business math right
now okay
if the demand is gonna go
up and the supply is going to go less
what does that mean well it's actually
going to be really good
for serviced accommodation providers
because it's going to mean that you get
more
more bookings it's going to mean that
because there's more demand and less
supply you'll be able to charge
more so i think serviced accommodation
from 4th of july
i think it's going to be really really
popular i'm really excited
my advice from a couple months ago i
said this i said look if you can't
afford to continue
if you've got a rent to service
accommodation and you're paying the
landlord a monthly rent and you haven't
got bookings
and you're really struggling worst case
hand the keys back
but try and hold it out and loads of my
students switched their service
accommodations
not back to buy to let's but switched it
around switched it up and instead of
advertising on booking.com and airbnb in
these places because they were blocked
they started just getting key workers
and putting nurses and nhs staff and
people in their properties
and they advertise themselves on social
media facebook even on gumtree
so a lot of my students have done quite
well with service accommodation which
you'll be hearing about on winners on a
wednesday
those that handed the keys back you now
here's my advice to you
you need to go and find those landlords
that have had their keys handed back and
are like oh no
okay they've just had the keys handed
back from rent to service to
accommodation entrepreneurs
and you need to go to them right now and
say i'll take your keys back
let's get a new contract let's fix a new
contract
and you need to go and find those
landlords because i tell you what
there's absolutely
hundreds of them not just in the uk all
across the world
in america australia all over europe
you don't have to do like you can
literally rent a property
and then you can you can then put that
property on airbnb
you can treat it as a hotel you're going
to be paying the landlord a small amount
you're going to be getting a
very very high profit as long as it's
done in the right way with the right
house
so i really am excited to see more
people become financially free through
service accommodation strategy there is
a little bit to it it's not as simple as
just renting a property and sticking it
on airbnb you need to make sure you've
got the correct management agreements
you need to make sure that you've got uh
if there's a head lease restricting it
you need to check that out you need to
make sure that there's not
any mortgage restrictions so there are
things you need to look at you also need
to make sure that demand is there
because this doesn't just work for any
house in any area has to be in an area
which is close by
to jobs and people and shops so
i have decided to run a webinar where
i'm going to be teaching
the in-depth strategies of serviced
accommodation
and if you'd like to do this strategy if
you want this to be your year if you
want to get some cash flow i'd really
suggest you come on the webinar it's
going to be some advanced training for
one hour with me
i'm going to be going through all the
ins and outs of service accommodation
and i'll be answering your questions on
the webinar as well
the webinar is going to be live and in
the link in the description
i'll leave a little link where you can
click on it you can book on it for free
wait for the webinar make sure you turn
up to the webinar and it's going to be
absolutely fantastic this is going to be
your year
this is the opportunity for financial
freedom and thank you for watching
subscribe smash the like button drop a
comment in but don't forget
register for the webinar it's free i'll
see you there